replaced by Jason zooker barabanov Goes Out High
and a shot right to the front handled that time
by Conor Ingram and the coyotes want to go oh big
juicy rebound there by Ingram good support though
defensively for the coyotes they got to start
playing better defensively bottom line four games
because of it now Uso valami all the way down for
Keller with a shot and now valami across Keller
again and sliding over his kinen behind the net
Michael Carone leads the coyotes and goals to the
line for Matt DBA and now Logan kie roer to the
front rebound keken and's got that little drop
for Moser to play Down Low H St him behind the
net and around the horn it goes Matt Dumba right
to the front bu stat was in front trying to get
a redirect comes out of the corner and back out
High th and a glove save as it bounces out of the
glove and into the corner taking away zooker great
effort trying to poke it along for Nick schaltz
Kyle granin with it granin will bring it right
back in barabanov Off the Bench and he shots and
a stop there by Conor Ingram Mario Ferraro bother
there Coyote's trying to move it along and Tomas
hdle is all the way back back to play that Red
Stick once again every year unbelievable what a
year Thomas turle is having once again leads the
San B sharks in literally every single category
offensively and he is the leader of this team
to be on up in front sto and cleared away chance
should never happened that puck came outside the
blue line no offside no whistle and there's
the big stop by Conor Ingram hurdle what a
pass we talked about him at the start of the
show it's a San Jose Shar in every offensive
category bomb almost got played in behind the net
kie out High kessle ring across derot with a shot
Travis Dermot and a stop by kinen and now Matt
Dumba gives away Moser and now Moser trying to
work it to the front GL save King and robbing
guess who four games that they've lost they've
been dominated in the circle and you look at JJ
Moser he gets involved jumps down low Lon CR he
pops out and get a beautiful feed by Moser and
Lawson K I think this just kind of rolls up on
him doesn't get all of it Addison Stripped Away
Krauss has it now Krauss to the front tried to
jam it there Matias melli was coming in hot and
he's got the puck across Moser shoots and a stop
that time keep an eye on Smith and Liam O'Brien
they had a conversation earlier in this period
shot right on granin great look he's been redot
David Quinn's group has been much better they've
been very good in the month of December Ferraro
towards the front somebody got their stick on it
that might have been ticketed short side that's
right so approachable so personable Ferraro
has it for burrow with a shot and that's on and
stopped by gooner Conor Ingram it's overextended
by about 26 seconds out high thrun now shot off
the pipe close call there for Yan Ruda face off
I talked about right it's a tire line top line
for the coyotes almost ends up in the back of
their net right off the post so Conor Ingram gets
a A Little Help from his buddy to the left of him
there
granin sharks try to bring it in grin's got it
little drop in front zerin poked away fire poker
and a rip Over the Top by declair and here's
a look look at it grin once again right to
the middle of the ice look at that right toe
pad save by Connor Ingram another massive stop
for to the line penalty is over duclair is out
here he comes duclair is in duclair he can't
get it pass on rolled off his stick after
that power play not jing a whole lot that
puck never sat down it was rolling the entire
time on Anthony declair who just came firing
out of that penalty box the Buffalo Savers
will be here tomorrow night as the co bring
it along here's an opportunity for bead he's
in he shoots stopped by cochan back towards
the front they had melli but they couldn't
get on the pck Moser shoots bouncing Puck
rebound they score they got melli this time as
he came to the front he buries said one nothing
coyotes if you can take the fourth line for
this this is a carryover effect and this buad
line continue to get it done look at buad in
front causing all sorts of traffic all sorts
of headaches and JJ mza throws it at the net big
juicy rebound onto the Stick of Matias belli and
he gets gold and now Michael Carone he feeds it
out High looking for [Applause] kie in behind the
suer for kie to the front oh and they can't bury
it a few shifts earlier gets real good wood on
that stick just enough tries to redirect that that
Puck and that pass by Logan coie play by [__]
on the goal Moser and now Keller K goes down low
comes across a little hot for kie he'll set it up
for schaltz across Keller and that rode up on Ken
in that's in good hustle there by Logan coie and
Nick small finds Keller back door I mean it's like
those guys share the same brain or hit on with the
bar serious momentum off of it and buuk Stat and
now flipped out of there by burrow brought right
back eckan down low to the front they try to jam
it home and they score on a rebound and the sharks
have tied it think that's eckan back down the
other way and look just short it out the net and
Conor Ingram makes a brilliant save here here's
the original stop right there that right padn
unable Sanford to to pick up ekan who just kind
of keeps on coming after the pass and he picks
up Arizona is challenging the play for golender
interference oh go tender interference there's
the Stick of Ingram comes up [Music] out look at
you can tell by the the movement Conor Ingram just
kind of gets pushed right back into to his net
so we're going to find out here Jordan Samuels
Thomas after video review it determined that
there was gender interference wow Quick Change
here 845 remaining leam mban is out there curl
move to the front Keller swwa away at it has his
Cur foot bami across ster brought it right
to the line turnover Moser got it to Center
Burrows there for San Jose kisel clear no it's
on side zerland trying to move it along poke
to the front grin scores oh the hands of miky
granley hottest players in the M the hockey
league and is that [Applause] upside they're
going to I'm sure take a look at that one good
keeping Zin and then granin just picks it up gets
a little bit of a lucky balance the coyotes were
all over it right around it and that puck ends
up on the stick of Gran Lin and beautiful move
backhand forehand right around Conor Ingram
Arizona challenging for offside so here we go
man oh here it is oh oh yeah that's
offsite after Arizona's challenge for offside
the play was determined to be offside no goal wow
the to 405 now le Bank he's got a look he shot it
over the top and wide and the coyotes have won and
Conor Ingram with his third shut out this season
and fourth in his National Hockey League career